hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 4
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet couple
really awesome things going on in this
episode they introduced a couple new
characters in a really big storyline
from the comics they're doing their
version of the firestorm protocols from
the new 52 so if you're not familiar
with that comic book storyline I'll
explain a little bit but in the name of
expediency because so much huge stuff is
happening this weekend I'm just gonna
hit all the most important stuff it was
a great episode mostly for Captain Cold
who's always amazing Wentworth Miller
needs his own show that's not Prison
Break into it was a really big firestorm
episode so the premise of the episode is
that were in the 80s Vandal Savage has
defected to the Soviet Union a cold war
still raging and he is secretly trying
to develop his own firestorm now you see
a whole bunch of test subjects they're
all dead so it's not like there's gonna
be millions of fire storms put the idea
in the comics the big storylines called
the firestorm protocols
it's the mechanisms and the methods for
becoming a firestorm Martin Stein
develops them but then he presumably
dies so it leaves behind this legacy
with ronnie raymond and jason rusch and
they have to protect it but it gets into
the hands of a bunch of different
governments so you wind up with fire
storms popping up all over the world and
you have what are called sanctioned fire
storms and unsanctioned fire storms it
literally turns into a nuclear arms race
so you have a lot of firestorm protocols
being traded on the black market those
become the unsanctioned firestorms so
just think of Vandal Savage firestorm
program as being an analog of the
Soviets in the United States developing
nuclear technology in real-world history
it's like oh you have the power to
destroy the world we have the power to
destroy the world now to the core that
Martin Stein is trying to steal in the
episode is the key in making those fire
storms so the Vandal Savage can't do
that anymore and we find out that
Valentina Vostok whose negative woman
from the comics is helping Vandal Savage
develop the technology if she looks
familiar
she was the wife of the antagonist from
mr. robot in season 1 so I was really
excited when she was cast for the show
she plays this really mysterious
character on mr. robot so I was just
like oh hell yeah please more Valentina
Vostok
and as the end of the episode implies
this is a two-part episode so like to
get captured at the end of the episode
next week will be the resolution to that
just to explain negative woman in the
comics a little bit she wasn't quite so
much a villain she was a Russian who
defected to the United States became
part of
patrol it was really a minor comic-book
character I was I was never a big fan of
the Doom Patrol comics so I'm totally
cool with whatever the TV show wants to
do with her but the most fun part of her
storyline is Captain cold just laying
the charm on no pun intended but he's
the coolest dude in that crew a lot of
the early marketing for the show and the
things that producers were saying about
the characters made it seem like Ray
Palmer was gonna be one of the leaders
but I really feel like Wentworth Miller
and Captain Colts character as it's
written in the show and as it's
performed has pulled the rug out from
anyone else that thinks that they're in
charge he is the runaway favorite from
this show and I think it's all because
Wentworth Miller is so charming I mean
the characters written really well too
so when a bunch of characters are
written really well it's the actors job
to turn it into something even bigger
and if you like what Wirth Miller has
just been crushing it but you know maybe
you guys have a different favorite
character on the show we're barely even
into the season and if you remember the
flash season one it really took the
first nine or 10 episodes for that show
to find some of its characters people
really didn't even start going crazy for
it till the back half like oh my god
this is the thing that's been going on
how have we missed this this is so
awesome so I feel like the same thing is
happening with legends of tomorrow and
you have to remember that a lot of these
characters are even smaller from the
comics like even lesser characters so
there's a lot of extra development work
to do like especially hawkgirl's
character she's a brand new hero fresh
off the press so her personality is
still emerging and I like the dichotomy
that they presented as in like her
warrior mode is an actual different
personality inside of her that takes
over some of you have been asking like
where her wings go when she's not
Hawkgirl think of it as a quasi
metahuman mystical ability as in Billy
Batson turning into Shazam I know they
changed the name technically his name's
Captain Marvel but DC is kind of played
with a naval a little bit her powers a
little more mystical than something that
could be explained by science like the
Dark Matter explosion and metahumans but
if you want to read the firestorm
protocols I mean I wasn't a really big
fan of the new 52 run in general that
was kind of an era of comics that I set
out and then went back and read later
like the stuff that I needed to
especially during flash season one the
firestorm protocols is the new 52 run a
firestorm collected in volume 2 so let
me know in the comments what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
who's your favorite character so far
remember there's 16 episodes so we're
not even halfway into the season so if
you feel like certain characters haven't
been developed as well as others there
will be episodes like that later in the
season I feel like we really
need a badass Adam episode because right
now the tone of his character feels a
little off I feel like he's gonna get
more cynical as the series goes on like
captain Colts personality will rub off
on him just like his personality rubs
off on Captain Cold
he spend enough time with a bunch of
people trapped in a tin can
flying through time and space you're
either one gonna kill each other or two
you're all gonna start thinking and
acting like each other but if you didn't
see it I just did a new trailer for the
flash next week they teased that they
might be revealing who zoom is he might
rip the masks off I'm not expecting it
to be that simple I think there'll be
some twists where it's like he that he
doesn't look like a character that we
know even though he's an earth 2 version
of a character that we've seen before
and there is a new game of Thrones
trailer that's going to be coming
tomorrow I'll do a video for that then
I'll do my Walking Dead video because
The Walking Dead's also back to fYI it's
gonna be a really awesome weekend really
busy Sunday too and giveaway time
congratulations to this week's
reverse-flash giveaway winner Mordecai
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'll start a new round
of the giveaway whenever I post my flash
video next week so while you guys wait
for that next video to post you can
click here for that flash trailer and
you can click here for my non-spoilery
Deadpool review be sure to go see
Deadpool this weekend thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight